this is the last question 7 m google
move on to exponential growth and decay
or friday but this question is in the
extension section and it sort of it so
it's a it's a perfect Avenue you into
actually exponential growth or decay so
you can see the picture and it's a bit
weird because it's a 2d picture for a 3d
diagram so in fact if you could arms if
you actually draw off on the side for
you and I'm going to turn this off there
because I did I need this space a dress
off a circle come in one which in a
minute is going to turn into a sphere so
the question we're looking at right it
puts this on a Cartesian planner we will
draw that in a moment but I want you to
understand what that T 2d image is
actually trying to represent right so
imagine a spirit if we're looking at it
from an angle your color key I want you
to picture where's blue any Bluetooth
water Oh Vicki ah I want you to picture
a disk of all right so if you look at
this from an angle okay so you kind of
looking down at it and so this is this
is all water here right and so what
you're looking at is there's Anna
surface area here okay some kind of
looking looking down in this thing and
it's evaporating that's all this is
talking about okay so we're trying to
wrap our head around the rate of change
here of the amount of water that's in
bed right so this is the picture now
this is the this is the actual cartesian
diagram that's going to help us
understand it's really quite clever okay
so if you want dropped while the same
circle in fact and then we're going to
put the Cartesian sort of information or
it'll help us actually use algebra to
solve this ok so is if you one
so this is kind of like the situation
you will see we will we will find this I
mean if you think about it if I view
this as a 2d beach which I'm now going
to draw you here's my arm can't even
claim what word are considering is well
this is actually a volume formed by
rotating around the vertical axis right
I could think of it that way and we know
how to work out those volumes so
therefore i can get expression all that
Molly even though it's a all good kind
of shape that's why we do that's
integration is perfect for this kind of
people okay good morning okay so here's
the situation we're now viewing this
flat so perfectly site on so this is
kind of the situation you're doing so
we're looking sideways there ok so the
3d do some of this image is kind of lost
it ok now the way they've set it up is
that they're saying this they're calling
a spherical cap cap is baby it's like it
doesn't seem obvious because it's
actually a cat will you be on the top
but it's the same shape except on the
bottom ok and it's formed when the
region between the lower half of the
circle come in can you fix it the lower
half of the circle x squared plus y
squared equals 16 so if that's the
equation of this circle and I also don't
the radius of this circle which is 4 so
4 here are negative for their it's and
that horizontal line that they've placed
it there which I've represented in blue
is the line y equals minus H ok so
therefore this distance here is H and
that could water note right there the
y-coordinate is my touch yep
okay yeah so it's a great question and
this will emerge as we start to go
through like what nikki is talking about
is if I want this volume right all i
really need to rotate around the y-axis
is that yeah and we see this all the
time like there's a an area and it's
above the axis and then when you were
here and you get the whole thing will
you get that big the fact okay now as
you'll see based on the equation of the
circle this kind of comes out excuse me
it comes out in the wash whether you
have both sides or just half the sign as
you'll send a middle so the first part
of question is well just supply the
volume can you get an expression for
that volume based on this occasion
product I want an expression for volume
so this is my rates of change question
yeah but this is going to give you the
expression which I can then say to me le
T in or anything now to get a volume
right if I rotated you don't to write
this but if I'm rotating a volume around
the x-axis right then i would say the
volume is V you to go from A to B if I'm
around the x-axis you dope I y squared
DX right and the way to do is like which
axis am I going around the axis is the
important thing and that's how you know
that's a DX right and that's NATO these
are X boundaries and this is going to be
a PI R squared H yes but I in fact i'm
not going around the x-axis I'm going
around the y-axis so I want this one i'm
going to change this to different
boundaries because they only why
Daenerys lot of expertise and here are a
swab everything room ok does that make
sense so this is what I'm after I'm
going to begin by writing this down now
look carefully um I want Y boundaries
what are my Y boundaries in this case
I'm going to go from negative 4 up to
negative H ok now i am going to write
that i will point out though that
because of the symmetry of this circle
right if I wanted to for
wanted to I could just as easily like do
you agree that this spherical cap is the
same as like that spherical cap right so
if i wanted to i could have gotten h24
as well as we started right down the
integrate here i'll let you think about
like why can i do that i just switch
that around apart from the geometric
argument there's an algebraic reason why
i would get the same answer okay but be
that this is where i'm looking at that's
where the diagram is I'm going to keep
these boundaries now what is law got a
pie what is x squared yeah very good I
don't even need to take like the square
roots or anything i have x squared right
there in my equation so if I just make
it the subject you can see that will be
the integrand I want that's what I'll
interact with respect to what ok so I'm
going to put in my 16 minus y squared a
c1 okay so against the rates of change
crushes yet I'm going to take this pie
out and they don't go to integrate um 16
turns into very good and minus y squared
22 cool so that's not too too hot I then
of course I've got my boundaries route
so good- for the bus okay so here's
where on that is that look okay yep now
this is a team se I can just tie this up
slightly by number one gave you my are H
terms in the right order for a
polynomial and also taking out that
fracture which is just making things a
little busy so I getting this edge cubes
minus 48 h possible tweeting a happy
looking good